Quel honneur ! Je me suis toujours demandé ce que ça ferait d'être là.
Il y a 8 ans, j'ai reçu le pire conseil de carrière de ma vie.
Un ami m'a dit :
« Ne t'inquiète pas d'aimer ou non ton travail actuel.
Il faut juste construire ton CV. »
Je revenais d'Espagne, où j'avais vécu un moment,
et avais rejoint cette entreprise du Fortune 500. Je me disais :
« C'est fantastique. Je vais avoir un impact sur le monde. »
J'avais plein d'idées. Et en deux mois,
j'ai remarqué que tous les jours, vers 10h du matin, j'avais envie
de taper ma tête contre l'écran de mon ordinateur.
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a déjà ressenti cela.
J'ai réalisé assez tôt après cela que les compétiteurs dans notre domaine
avaient déjà automatisé mon travail.
C'est à ce moment-là que j'ai reçu ce sage conseil de construire mon CV.
Alors que j'essaye de déterminer
de quelle fenêtre du 2ème étage j'allais sauter et changer les choses.
J'ai lu des conseils différents de la part de Warren Buffett qui disait :
« Accepter un poste uniquement pour le CV c'est comme réserver le sexe
pour quand vous serez vieux. »
(Rires)
J'ai entendu cela, c'était ce qu'il me fallait.
En deux semaines, j'étais parti avec une seule intention :
trouver quelque chose que je pourrais foirer.
C'en était si dur.
Je voulais avoir un impact, quel qu'il soit.
J'ai rapidement découvert que je n'étais pas seul :
il s'avère que plus de 80% des personnes
n'aiment pas leur travail.
Peut-être pas dans cette pièce,
mais c'est la moyenne faite par Deloitte grâce à leurs études.
Je voulais découvrir ce qui sépare les gens,
ceux qui ont un travail passionnant, qui changent le monde,
qui se réveillent inspirés,
et ces personnes, les autres 80%
qui mènent ces vies de désespoir silencieux.
J'ai interviewé ces personnes faisant un travail passionnant,
j'ai lu des livres, j'ai fait des études de cas,
300 livres au total sur les objectifs et la carrière.
Une immersion totale, pour l'égoïste raison --
je voulais trouver le travail que je ne pouvais pas ne pas faire,
qui était fait pour moi.
Et de plus en plus de personnes me demandaient :
« Tu fais ce truc de carrière.
Je n'aime pas mon travail, on déjeune ensemble ? »
J'acceptais mais je les prévenais
que mon taux de démission était de 80%.
Des personnes avec lesquelles je déjeunais, 80% démissionnaient
dans les 2 mois.
J'en étais fier. Non pas que j'étais magicien.
Je posais une simple question :
« Pourquoi faites-vous le travail que vous faites ? »
Souvent la réponse était :
« Parce que quelqu'un m'a dit que j'étais censé le faire. »
J'ai réalisé que de nombreuses personnes
montent cette échelle que quelqu'un leur a dit de monter,
et il s'avère qu'elle est posée contre le mauvais mur,
voire contre aucun mur.
Plus je passais de temps avec ces personnes, plus je voyais ce problème.
Je me demandais : si nous créions une communauté,
un endroit où les gens se sentiraient à leur place,
où on pouvait faire les choses différemment,
où on encourageait à sortir des sentiers battus
et inspirait les gens à changer ?
C'est ensuite devenu ce que j'appelle : « Vivez Votre Légende »
et que je vais expliquer.
En faisant ces découvertes, j'ai remarqué un cadre
composé de trois choses simples
qu'ont en commun toutes ces personnes passionnées qui changent le monde.
Que vous soyez Steve Jobs,
ou le propriétaire de la boulangerie en bas de la rue,
votre travail incarne qui vous êtes.
Je veux partager avec vous ces 3 choses, pour les avoir comme objectifs
pour le reste de la journée, et, j'espère, de votre vie.
La première étape de ce cadre de travail passionné
est de devenir un expert de soi-même et se comprendre
parce que si vous ne savez pas ce que vous cherchez,
vous ne le trouverez jamais.
Et personne ne le fera à votre place.
Il n'y a pas de majeure à la fac sur la passion, l'objectif et la carrière.
Cela devrait être une majeure obligatoire,
ne me lancez pas sur le sujet.
Vous passez plus de temps à choisir votre télévision
qu'à choisir votre majeure et votre domaine d'études.
Le fait est que c'est à nous de déterminer cela
et nous avons besoin d'un cadre, d'un guide à travers cela.
Le premier point de notre boussole est de trouver nos forces uniques.
Quelles sont les choses que nous aimons toujours en nous levant,
que nous soyons payé ou non, celles pour lesquelles on nous remercie ?
Strengths Finder 2.0 est un livre et un outil en ligne.
Je le recommande fortement pour trouver ce pour quoi vous êtes naturellement doué.
Ensuite, quel est notre cadre, notre hiérarchie dans la prise de décision ?
Accordons-nous de l'importance aux gens, notre famille, notre santé
ou est-ce à la réussite et le succès ?
Afin de prendre des décisions, nous devons le savoir,
savoir de quoi est faite notre âme,
afin de ne pas la vendre à une cause dont nous n'avons rien à faire.
Puis vient l'étape suivante : nos expériences.
Nous avons tous ces expériences. A chaque minute, nous apprenons des choses
sur ce que nous aimons ou détestons,
ce pour quoi nous sommes doués ou non.
Si nous n'accordons pas assez d'attention à cela,
à assimiler cette connaissance,
à l'appliquer pour le reste de notre vie, cela ne sert à rien.
Chaque jour, chaque semaine, chaque mois
je passe du temps à réfléchir à ce qui s'est bien passé,
ce qui s'est mal passé, ce que je veux répéter.
ce que je peux appliquer plus.
Plus que cela même, afin que, quand vous voyez des personnes
qui vous inspirent, qui agissent et vous dites :
« Ce que Jeff fait... Je veux être comme lui. »
Pourquoi dites-vous cela ? Ouvrez un carnet.
Ecrivez ce qui vous inspire chez eux.
Ce ne sera pas toute leur vie,
mais quoi que ce soit, notez-le.
Ainsi, au fil du temps, vous aurez ce recueil de choses
que vous pouvez appliquer à votre vie pour avoir une existence plus passionnée
et avoir un meilleur impact.
Car quand on commence à collecter ces choses,
nous pouvons définir ce que le succès signifie pour nous.
Ce qui est impossible sans ces différentes parties de la boussole.
Nous sommes dans une situation -- une vie déjà écrite
que tout le monde semble vivre, grimpant une échelle ne menant nulle part.
C'est comme dans Wall Street 2, si vous l'avez vu,
l'employé demande au PDG d'une grande banque de Wall Street. :
« C'est quoi votre somme ? Tout le monde en a une.
Une somme d'argent. Une fois atteinte, on quitte tout. »
Il dit : « C'est simple : plus. »
Et il sourit.
Et c'est la triste idée de la majorité de ceux
n'ayant pas compris ce qui compte pour eux,
qui essayent d'atteindre un objectif sans signification,
parce que tout le monde dit qu'on est censé le faire.
Une fois ce cadre posé,
nous pouvons identifier les choses qui nous font nous sentir en vie.
Avant cela, une passion pouvait vous frapper de plein fouet,
ou peut-être que dans votre travail, vous l'abandonneriez
parce que vous n'avez pas moyen de l'identifier.
Mais une fois cela fait, vous trouvez une chose cohérente avec vos forces,
vos valeurs, la personne que vous êtes.
Je vais empoigner cela et en faire quelque chose.
Je vais le poursuivre, essayer d'avoir un impact.
« Vivez Votre Légende » et le mouvement que nous avons créé
n'existeraient pas sans cette boussole pour identifier
ce que l'on veut poursuivre, où on veut avoir un impact.
Si on ne sait pas ce que l'on cherche, on ne le trouvera jamais.
Mais avec ce cadre, cette boussole,
nous pouvons aller de l'avant -- ce n'est pas moi --
accomplir l'impossible, repousser nos limites.
Les gens n'agissent pas pour deux raisons.
La première est qu'ils se disent qu'ils n'en sont pas capables,
où leur entourage le leur dit.
Dans tous les cas, on le croit,
on abandonne ou on n'essaye jamais.
Le fait est que tout était impossible jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un le fasse.
Chaque invention, chaque nouvelle chose
était perçue comme une idée folle.
Roger Bannister et le mile en 4 minutes : c'était physiquement impossible
de courir un mile en moins de 4 minutes
jusqu'à ce que Roger Bannister le fasse.
Que s'est-il passé ensuite ?
Deux mois plus tard, 16 personnes l'ont fait.
Ce que nous avons en tête et pensons impossible,
ce ne sont souvent que des étapes accomplies
en repoussant un peu les limites.
Cela commence avant tout avec votre corps, votre condition physique,
car nous voulons le contrôler.
Si vous pensez ne pas pouvoir courir un mile,
prouvez-vous que vous pouvez en courir deux,
ou un marathon, ou perdre 3 kg, quoi que ce soit.
Réalisez que la confiance se constitue
et peut être transmise au reste du monde.
J'ai moi-même pris cette habitude avec mes amis.
Nous avons un petit groupe, nous accomplissons des défis physiques.
Récemment, je me suis trouvé dans une situation précaire.
Les eaux profondes me terrifient.
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a déjà eu la même peur
après avoir regardé 6 fois la série « Les dents de la mer »
étant enfant.
Tout ce qui est au-dessus de ce point, même si c'est trouble, je peux le sentir.
Je vous promets qu'il y a quelque chose.
Même dans le Lac Tahoe. C'est de l'eau douce, ma peur est infondée,
ridicule, mais elle est bien là.
Il y a trois ans, je me suis retrouvé dans un remorqueur
dans la baie de San Francisco.
C'est une journée pluvieuse, venteuse, les gens sont malades sur le bateau.
Je suis assis, portant une combinaison et je regarde par la fenêtre,
profondément terrifié à l'idée de nager jusqu'à en mourir.
Je vais essayer de traverser le Golden Gate à la nage.
Je pense que certains d'entre vous ont déjà fait cela.
Je suis assis, mon pote Jonathan, qui m'a convaincu de le faire,
il est venu me voir et a vu l'état dans lequel j'étais.
Il a dit : « Scott, que pourrait-il arriver de pire ?
Tu portes une combinaison. Tu ne couleras pas.
Et si tu n'y arrives pas, tu peux monter dans un des 20 kayaks.
Et si un requin attaque, pourquoi te choisirait-il
parmi les 80 personnes dans l'eau ? » Merci. Cela aide.
« Mais vraiment, amuse-toi. Bonne chance. »
Et il plonge et nage. OK.
Il s'avère que ses encouragements ont fonctionné.
Je me sentais très calme.
Je pense que c'est parce que Jonathan avait 13 ans.
(Rires)
Et parmi les 80 personnes nageant ce jour-là,
65 d'entre elles avaient entre 9 et 13 ans.
Pensez à combien votre approche du monde aurait été différente
si à 9 ans vous aviez découvert que vous pouviez nager 2,5km
dans une eau à 13°C, d'Alcatraz à San Francisco.
A quoi auriez-vous dit oui ?
Que n'auriez-vous pas abandonné ? Qu'auriez-vous essayé ?
Alors que je finis de nager, j'arrive au parc aquatique,
je sors de l'eau et,
bien-sûr, la moitié des enfants a déjà fini
donc ils me félicitent et ils sont tout excités.
J'ai la tête gelée, si vous vous en doutez,
et j'essaye me réchauffer en regardant les gens finir.
Je vois cet enfant, quelque chose ne va pas.
Et il gesticulait ainsi.
Il est à peine capable de respirer avant que sa tête ne retourne sous l'eau.
J'ai remarqué que d'autres parents regardaient aussi.
Je promets qu'ils pensaient comme moi :
c'est pour cela qu'on ne laisse pas un enfant de 9 ans nager depuis Alcatraz.
Ce n'était pas de la fatigue.
Tout à coup, deux parents ont couru l'attraper,
l'ont mis sur leurs épaules et l'ont tiré ainsi,
il était tout mou.
Ils ont fait quelques pas de plus
et l'ont installé dans sa chaise roulante.
Il a levé ses points dans la démonstration de victoire la plus folle jamais vue.
Je ressens toujours la chaleur et l'énergie de ce gamin
quand il a accompli ce défi.
Je l'avais vu, plus tôt ce jour-là, dans sa chaise roulante.
Je ne pensais pas qu'il allait nager.
Où sera-t-il dans 20 ans ?
Combien de personnes lui ont dit qu'il ne pouvait pas le faire,
qu'il mourrait s'il essayait ?
Vous donnez tort aux autres et à vous-même,
prouvez que vous pouvez progressivement
atteindre ce en quoi vous croyez.
Pas besoin d'être le plus rapide coureur du marathon,
simplement accomplir vos propres impossibilités
et cela commence par de petits pas.
La meilleure façon de le faire
est de vous entourer de personnes passionnées.
Le plus rapide pour faire des choses que vous pensez impossibles
est de vous entourer de personnes les faisant déjà.
Il a cette citation de Jim Rohn :
« Vous êtes la moyenne des 5 personnes avec lesquelles vous passez votre temps. »
Il n'y a pas eu de meilleure astuce de vie dans l'histoire
pour aller d'où vous êtes à où vous voulez aller
que les personnes que vous choisissez d'avoir à vos côtés.
Elles changent tout, c'est prouvé.
En 1898, Norman Triplett a réalisé cette étude avec des cyclistes.
Il mesurait leur temps au tour quand ils étaient en groupe
et seuls.
Il a découvert que les cyclistes dans un groupe roulaient toujours plus vite.
Cette étude a depuis été refaite dans tous les domaines
et a toujours prouvé la même chose :
votre entourage compte et l'environnement est important.
Mais c'est à vous de le contrôler car cela va dans les deux sens.
Avec 80% de personnes n'aimant ce qu'elles font,
la plupart des personnes nous entourant, pas ici, mais partout ailleurs,
encouragent la complaisance
et nous empêchent de poursuivre ce qui nous importe.
Nous devons gérer cet entourage.
Je me suis trouvé dans une situation --
un exemple personnel, il y a quelques années.
Quelqu'un a déjà eu un loisir, une passion pour laquelle il s'investissait éperdument
et y passait énormément de temps, si bien qu'il voulait en faire une entreprise
mais personne n'y prête attention et cela ne rapporte pas d'argent ?
J'ai été dans ce cas durant 4 ans pour bâtir le mouvement « Vivez Votre Légende »
et aider les gens à faire un travail qui leur importe et les inspire.
Je faisais tout mon possible
et seulement 3 personnes y prêtaient attention :
ma mère, mon père et ma femme, Chelsea.
Merci pour le soutien.
(Applaudissements)
Je le voulais tellement. La croissance était de 0% durant 4 ans,
j'allais tout arrêter
et à ce moment-là,
j'ai déménagé à San Francisco et j'ai rencontré des personnes intéressantes
qui avaient ces styles de vie, ces entreprises, ces sites et blogs
fous et aventureux
qui se rapportaient à leur passion et aidaient significativement les gens.
Un de mes amis qui a 8 enfants
subvient aux besoins de toute sa famille
avec un blog dans lequel il publie deux fois par semaine.
Ils reviennent d'un mois en Europe, ils y étaient tous ensemble.
Cela m'a époustouflé. Comment est-ce possible ?
Cela m'a beaucoup inspiré.
Au lieu de tout arrêter, j'ai décidé de le prendre sérieusement.
J'ai fait tout mon possible pour passer mon temps,
chaque heure, à harceler ces personnes,
à sortir, boire des bières, faire du sport avec eux.
Après 4 ans sans croissance,
en 6 mois à passer du temps avec ces personnes,
la communauté de « Vivez Votre Légende » a été multipliée par 10.
En 12 autres mois, elle a été multipliée par 160.
Aujourd'hui, plus de 30 000 personnes venant de 158 pays
utilisent tous les mois nos outils de carrière et de connexion.
Ces personnes ont créé cette communauté de passionnés
qui m'ont inspiré l'idée
de « Vivez Votre Légende » il y a tant d'années.
Les gens changent tout, c'est pourquoi --
vous vous demandiez ce qu'il se passait.
Pendant 4 ans, je ne connaissais personne dans le secteur
et je ne savais même pas qu'il existait, que des personnes agissaient,
que ces mouvements existaient.
Puis, à San Francisco, tout le monde agissait.
C'est devenu la norme. Ma réflexion est passée
de comment pourrais-je le faire
à comment pourrais-je ne pas le faire.
Alors vous avez un déclic,
cela impacte tout votre monde.
Sans même essayer, vos standards vont d'ici à ici.
Pas besoin de changer vos objectifs, simplement votre environnement.
C'est tout. Et c'est pour cela que j'aime m'entourer de ce groupe de personnes,
que je vais à toutes les conférences TED possibles,
que je les regarde sur ma tablette en allant au travail.
Car c'est le groupe de personnes qui inspire la possibilité.
Nous avons toute une journée à passer ensemble, voire plus.
Pour résumer, ces trois piliers
ont tous une chose en commun :
nous les contrôlons à 100%.
Personne ne peut vous dire que vous ne pouvez pas
en apprendre sur vous-même ;
repousser vos limites
et déterminer votre impossible pour le repousser ;
vous entourer de personnes qui vous inspirent
ou vous éloigner de celles qui vous tirent vers le bas.
Vous ne contrôlez pas la récession,
ni le fait d'être viré ou d'avoir un accident de voiture.
La plupart des choses sont hors de contrôle.
Nous contrôlons ces choses-là
et elles peuvent changer notre monde si nous décidons d'agir.
Le fait est que cela se produit à grande échelle.
Je viens de lire dans Forbes que c'est la première fois
qu'en un mois, plus de personnes avaient démissionné
que de personnes avaient été virées.
C'était perçu comme une anomalie, mais cela a duré 3 mois.
A une époque où les gens disent que l'environnement est difficile,
ils envoient balader leur vie pré-écrite,
ce qu'ils sont censés faire,
au profit de ce qui leur importe et ce qui les inspire.
Le fait est que les gens découvrent cette idée
que seule leur imagination limite leurs possibilités.
Ce n'est plus un cliché.
Peu importe ce qui vous intéresse, votre passion, votre loisir.
Si vous aimez tricoter, vous pouvez trouver quelqu'un qui en fait sa vie
et en apprendre de cette personne. C'est fou.
C'est le but de cette journée, d'en apprendre des intervenants.
A « Vivez Votre Légende », nous cherchons ces personnes
parce que quand des gens ordinaires accomplissent l'extraordinaire
et que nous nous en entourons,
cela devient la norme.
Il n'est pas question d'être Gandhi ou Steve Jobs, de faire une chose folle.
Il est question de faire ce qui compte pour vous
et avoir un impact que seul vous pouvez avoir.
En parlant de Gandhi, c'était un ancien avocat,
à ce que j'ai entendu,
il a été appelé par une plus grande cause, qui comptait pour lui,
il ne pouvait pas ne pas agir.
Et je vis par cette citation :
« D'abord ils vous ignorent, ensuite ils vous raillent,
puis ils vous combattent et enfin, vous gagnez. »
Tout était impossible, jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un le fasse.
Vous pouvez vous entourez de gens vous disant que c'est impossible
et que vous êtes stupide d'essayer.
Ou vous entourer de gens qui vous inspirent des possibilités,
des gens dans cette pièce.
Il est de notre responsabilité de montrer au monde
que ce qui parait impossible peut devenir la nouvelle norme.
Cela commence à se produire.
Premièrement, faire ce qui nous inspire
afin d'inspirer les autres à faire ce qui les inspire.
Mais nous ne trouverons pas cela
si nous ne savons pas quoi chercher.
Nous devons intentionnellement travailler sur nous-même,
et faire ces découvertes.
Car j'imagine un monde où 80% des personnes aiment leur travail.
A quoi ressemblerait-il ?
Que serait l'innovation ? Comment traiteriez-vous votre entourage ?
Les choses changeraient.
Pour finir, j'ai une question pour vous
et c'est la seule question qui importe :
quel travail ne pouvez-vous pas ne pas faire ?
Trouvez-le, vivez-le,
pas seulement pour vous, mais pour votre entourage
car cela commence à changer le monde.
Quel travail ne pouvez-vous pas ne pas faire ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)